姉さん世の中にはいろんな種類のお菓子したいと思いますね一番ホテルで誰でも考え
てろ頭に変わりますでしたそう
迷子です私は思ってしまった甘いもやっ速て美味しいですよね10円で1個100円で
10個1000円で
しゃっことあるでしょ伝世そこで私は思っています
う前も10万個ってどれくらいなんだろう素直にそう思って翔ちゃ
あっ
はいというわけで100万円企画の日本100万円買ってみたでございます
[音楽]
san
あの勢全員に個人的には m 500枚分買ったらどれくらいの量になるのかなーって
思って貼ってみましたもう業生産が来てるんで取りに行ってみましょう
ポンとちょっとした出来心なんですようわっあのタッカーで消え
べくに2台おはようございます
いやーもう100万円向かってみたんですよ
ん
[音楽]
これの後に by あるみたいですちょっと思ったよりおいしいねー
ん
ええええええええええええ
[音楽]
ん
あるいは本当にテンポっ
調整しましたあるいはこっでめちゃめちゃいます
dee ん
[音楽]
100万円部枚も買うのがネットだとメルだったんで直接
うまい棒とっている会社でしたさんから貫通いたしましたですかありがとうございまし
たはいというわけでうまい棒100万円便届きました
表面だけでもこれでその中にもうまい棒が待ってるんですけどなんか見てみましょう
いやもうせますぎる愛ここから全部
うまい棒になってまして
これずっとどうするのが今も全部うまい棒
ahkah これでツンなら
愛というわけで甘い500万円分買ったので今からこの部屋に甘いを割くマン演武運び
ました
この一般的な部屋に甘い落ち込むとどれくらいの量になるのかなっていうのを見たい
畑です
います絶対端っこから上でた方が良いんじゃなしこ母
ああああああ
なんで何通りかでこのレベルか
ています
ええええええ
ああああああいいし
うわこれやばいマジで家が生まれた分
[音楽]
言われただけでまだ良いでしょ
ん
voodoo
rar
矢部愛というわけでえええ
ヘアニューバイブを100万円を入れてみたんですけど多いですねあそこに甘い語を
たくさん買うと安全遊舞山になってしまいました
とりあえず100万円あればまあ部屋いっぱいうまい子だれ気になるなっていうのは
わかりました
今からつる兄が家に来るんですけどやっぱりさしぶりに映るに遊びにくるんですよ
も女性今どこ強いつる兄さーん
好きなお菓子何
好きなお花を
ですかね愛と呼び年前も好きみたいですね
これだけの量のうまい棒があると人ってパニくると思うんですよ
多少の量だったらうわーってなると思うんですけども信じられないような甘いんぽうを
目の前にして彼は第一声何を話すのかとても気になるところでございますそれでは彼が
来るのを待ちましょう
dee
はーはっはっはっえっ
まあ
b
食べていいですか yeah
me
teame
wh 8版
いやのっきーてはかけすぎじゃないですよ
えーっ100万曲なんてわからのですのあーあの100万円愚昧わかったんですけど
早速にこれはスタッフで食べますとは言えないのである程度あの僕とか
マリオ友達とかみんなで食べますで残りはなんかな本が折れちゃってると思うんです
けど
俺でなきゃいけねーつはちょっとしたら皆さんに配れる機械とかをするかもしれないの
でみなさんお楽しみに
夢か
馬ですあやっ